[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in carson palmer the former
nfl quarterback you must have tears in
your eyes watching the bengals go to the
afc title game
oh i loved it i loved it i loved it for
the city i loved it uh for that young
team and joe burrow especially
you know when you have that you're
turning everything over to your kicker
like what's that feeling like that
you've done everything you're supposed
to do as the quarterback and then the
kicker is going to decide like how
helpless is that
it's scary and and you know it's it
seems so simple but you go stand out
there on that field and the wind is
swirling and you look up at how narrow
those uprights are and think about how
fast those guys have to do that and how
accurate they have to be it's a it's a
job i wouldn't want
i know you've talked about joe burrow
but
like
these young quarterbacks just don't seem
that young anymore when they're 22 23 24
out there and like i don't know
how you teach that with these younger
quarterbacks uh or is it something that
that can be taught to be calm under
pressure under fire
you you can't teach what joe burrows
doing right now i mean to see him get
sacked nine times in a game and
and
the amazing thing
as a former quarterback watching it is
is i know how deflating each sack can be
and and this game especially at this
point in the season is all about
momentum and it's such a momentum killer
when you get sacked to not freak out to
not make a bad decision to not you know
try to flip one out of bounds and avoid
the sack and end up being a sack fumble
or a pick i mean he is so calm and cool
under such tremendous pressure uh and
and i think that's what what is jumping
out on the film to me is he just looks
so much older than he actually is
that game last night you got the feeling
that these two are going to see a lot of
each other the rest of their careers
almost like a brady peyton manning type
feel to it back and forth what did you
take away from the chiefs beating the
bills
yeah i mean the top dogs stayed on top
uh at the end of the day we keep looking
for the next patrick mahomes and wanting
to anoint josh allen in burrow but the
big dog won i mean at the end of the day
the best quarterback in the league
is still playing and josh gave him a run
for his money and that buffalo team that
uh
is there is so much excitement in the
future that young buffalo team but we we
did you know we saw the beginning of uh
the next great duel of those two
quarterbacks
yeah i was wondering
you know with the kickoff and tony romo
said this in real time he's like i don't
want to have a touch back i i want them
to run the clock a little bit like have
a squib kick a pooch kick something like
that what did you think of that strategy
yeah i mean it's it 13 seconds is truly
amazing for them to move the ball that
quickly that fast with that little time
um
any time on the clock is too much you've
got i mean looking back they've got to
swim that you've got to take as much
time off the clock and out of out of
patrick mahone's hands as you can
and you need two 20-yard plays like i
don't know how you process that
and when you're in the huddle and you
know you're going to need 40 yards to
get in field goal range there of
you know you got three timeouts left but
it was just straight it felt like
buffalo was playing the sidelines they
had three timeouts i didn't understand
the strategy of of the buffalo bills
defense
yeah and at the end of the day you never
think when you have the ball in that
situation that the defense is going to
be bad enough to give up 20 to 20 yard
plays you're like this is the nfl these
guys will not actually do this and then
sure enough boom boom two plays in a row
and they completely change the field
position sometimes you give i know it
was a problem for me and there's
something pete carroll worked with me
all the time is is giving the defense
too much respect these are the best of
the best these the nfl guys at the end
of the day they make mistakes they blow
coverages and they did it right there
well you saw that in the buccaneers game
against the rams like how do you how do
you forget where cooper cup is a couple
of times
yeah i mean that that covers zero blitz
in that situation and not getting home
and given that you know he had stafford
had just enough time before
uh and dominic and sue got a piece of
him and letting the best player on the
field run down the middle of the field
wide open at the end of the game for the
winner is just some you know that's just
a back breaker
it felt like there was a little finality
to it with brady i know it's right after
the fact when you lose and you go to the
press conference normally he he says i'm
coming back he said i need to take some
time here
the same thing with aaron rodgers feels
like roger's going to play again the
question is is he going to play with
green bay
which do you think is more likely to
happen brady is done or aaron rodgers is
done in green bay
i think brady is 100 coming back and i
think aaron rodgers is also coming back
but not to the green bay packers i think
it was a win it
uh and and if they had won it and and
the organization could prove that they
were a super bowl caliber organization
then then you know he finishes his
career there and hopefully wins a couple
more now i think all bets are off i i
think aaron will be switching teams
what team makes the most sense
from his standpoint denver i mean that
roster is ready that's a that's a really
good defensive front um it's really good
on the back end they've been under vic
fangio for a long time it's a smart
defense team that's been around a really
veteran play caller uh and offensively
they got some they got some weapons
outside kind of devonte style weapons
and and um in some size and and i think
that's probably the best team it's going
to the toughest division but that's
probably the best team that's that's
that's you know super bowl ready yeah
i'm there with you i i think that
they're uh kind of a sneaky giant ready
to emerge there i know it's in the in
the afc west but i i think denver's got
a ton of talent there
and they can give up draft picks to get
aaron rodgers uh why do you say brady
100 sure he's coming back
i just think the year he had i mean the
numbers he put up the level he played at
if he wins in another mvp and didn't go
to the super bowl i mean that's just
enough another chip on his shoulder i
think 100 will see brady back next year
in a buck uniform what about the titans
with ryan tannehill
i know he's at a good price for a
starting quarterback
but
is he holding them back
well you you saw his his um
you know at the end of the day that
that's what cost them the game is his
play unfortunately um
but the ulterior is not any better for
them they're not going to find somebody
drafting at 26 or 27 whatever it is
they're going to be picking at um
you know ryan has has gotten them a
first round bye at the end of the day
he's gotten them to that level they need
to make the next steps and maybe improve
around him but he is 100 percent the
best quarterback uh that they're going
to find at this point and and that the
next point of going in the next season
would you rather have carson wentz or
ryan tannehill
ryan tannehill 100
how about jimmy garoppolo
jimmy just jimmy's got nine lives i mean
it's amazing how do you explain that
carson he's he's a game away from going
back to a super bowl he had 106 yards
broken thumbs sprained shoulder he just
finds a way it's amazing he's on his
ninth life for sure i know but
um why now
trying to beat somebody three times in a
season you know the niners trying to
beat the rams and look the rams looked
unbelievable and then they looked so
vulnerable on the same game
i just have i have no idea what to
expect i'm not surprised they won the
game against tampa but i i still can be
surprised when i watch them be so good
and so bad in the same game
they're in an interesting spot the the
la rams did not want to draw the san
francisco 49ers in the playoffs they do
not match up well they've got their
number they're in their heads they know
it they've beat them at their own
stadium before it's just it is the one
team they did not want to play it is the
one team that the rants do not match up
well with
what is it that san francisco does that
gives the rams so much trouble
well they can get after you with four
they don't have to bring a ton of
different pressures but they do do a
really good job of pressuring um i mean
some of the personnel wise i mean it you
can put bosa on both sides so he doesn't
get stuck
on the left tackle at all the time they
can bring him on the inside he's great
at stunts it's just a bad match and a
bad draw for them good to talk to you as
always thanks enjoy the games coming up
next weekend
we'll do thanks dan that's carson palmer
former nfl quarterback heisman trophy
winner brought to you by level select
cbd the next level relief visit
levelselectcbd.com